now the state notified clark county that  its local cobit 19 mitigation and  enforcement plan can go into effect  saturday those plans include some  changes like upping capacity from 50 to  80 percent  reducing social distancing from six down  to three feet  and also allowing restaurants to seat  twelve people at a table instead of six  buffets day clubs and night clubs will  also be allowed to reopen  now something to keep in mind once clark  county hits 60 percent of residents  having at least one vaccine dose  all social distancing and capacity  limits will just  go away and don't forget on june 1st  governor sisilak has set a goal for  every county in nevada to reopen  at 100 capacity but that's going to  depend on how well we do between now  and june 1st